bonjour à tous
merci d'être là
écoutez je vais commencer par vous faire
une confidence
lorsque j'étais invité à participer
aujourd'hui à ceux d'aix
j'étais en pleine préparation de ma
plaidoirie devant la cour spéciale
la cour d'assises spécialement composée
à paris c'est
c'est aujourd'hui le procès
en france et dans le monde le plus
le plus important c'est un procès
historique c'est un procès hors norme
c'est un procès où il ya deux plus de
2005 sont victimes
131 morts
et je me suis dit je vais commencer
par vous dire ce que j'ai dit en
m'adressant à la cour je voudrais juste
vous dire que ce n'était pas une cour
composée par des jurys des gens de la
société civile c'était une cour composée
par des magistrats professionnels dans
la majorité des femmes d'ailleurs
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs de la cour
dans le monde
idéal de ces accusés
ici à ma place il y aurait un homme et
non une femme
une femme même voilée ne peut être juge
ni procureur ni avocat ni rien
d'ailleurs
c'est une hérésie
que moi femme
avocate puisse être ce jour-là
et plaider devant votre cour
le sujet du labyrinthe m'a beaucoup
inspiré
le labyrinthe cet endroit clos où
il est difficile de trouver son chemin
pour la sortie et lorsqu'on a
l'impression de l'avoir trouvé en fait
c'est un mur c'est une impasse il n'y a
pas de sortie alors comment s'en sortir
autrement que par l'eau
cette idée exceptionnel extraordinaire
elle a été
trouvée par des dalles
lorsqu'il était enfermée avec i car son
fils dans le labyrinthe qui l'a inventé
il a inventé un labyrinthe ici est
trouvé il n'arrivait pas à s'en sortir
alors comment faire eh bien
il a façonné
des ailes pour son fils et car
je reprends la mythologie la mythologie
grecque
il a façonné des ailes pour cent son
fils et car pour lui permettre de sortir
de cette prison à ciel ouvert parce
qu'il a compris qu'on ne pouvait s'en
sortir que par le haut
c'est elle était en cire et en plumes et
lorsqu'il s'est envolé
pour
retrouver sa liberté et défier les
oiseaux vous savez ce qui est arrivé
plus tard se rapprocher du ciel plus la
catastrophe s'approcher de lui parce que
la serre a fondu
et les plumes en brûler et puis une fois
sorti une fois dehors il faut pas
oublier c'est pas fini une fois dehors
il ya le
minotaure ce thème ce personnage
mythique mi homme mi taureau qui vous
guette à la sortie et puis il se nourrit
exclusivement de chair humaine
et puis
ils guettent
n'importe quel faux pas n'importe quel
état de faiblesse n'importe quel doute
pour vous pour vous dévorer
alors je vais être honnête avec vous moi
ma sortie du labyrinthe
mais
différentes tentatives de sortie pour
être plus juste n'ont pas toutes été
couronnées de succès
je suis tombé je me suis relevé j'ai
chuté je me suis
débrouillé pour essayer de au moins
garder la tête en dehors du labyrinthe
vous savez lorsque on est né dans une
société où des décennies durant voire
des siècles la femme a été derrière ce
ses murs du labyrinthe dans la
claustration
il fallait trouver
je dirais même instinctivement
la force de se relever et de sortir
alors moi j'ai eu la chance j'ai eu
l'immense chance de naître dans cette
tunisie c'est tunisie où un visionnaire
habib bourguiba
qui a compris lui qu'il faut émanciper
les femmes pour émanciper tout un peuple
parce que pour lui les femmes ne sont
pas des complémentaires les femmes sont
essentiels les femmes ne sont pas des
complémentaires comme le rêvait et le
reste encore des islamistes intégristes
dans notre pays
ils n'ont pas peur du labyrinthe cela
mais débouchera des failles celle des
confrères des avocats sont tous là pour
ne pas
laissez le minotaure
nous avaler nous non seulement femmes
mais un peuple entier
vous savez
ça a été rappelée à l'instant je suis
désolé et à une partie de ma famille qui
est là mais je dois vous le dire oui moi
ma sortie du labyrinthe je lai d'abord
fait
dans la petite cellule familiale fille
unique avec cinq garçons il fallait
trouver sa place alors j'ai laissé
pousser des ailes
et je les ai confectionné j'ai fait en
sorte que ça soit en matière
ininflammable invincible pour pouvoir
avancer
et ne pas subir le sort d'icare
parce que je connais le monde misogyne g
avec ses ailes j'ai dû faire
des effets de manche un peu plus tard
mais c'est
il fallait que je me pose mais avant de
s'imposer il fallait se faire accepter
alors oui j'ai joué aux toupies je n'ai
pas joué à la poupée parce qu'il fallait
que je sois accepté par ce monde de
garçons je ne voulais pas être victimes
d'une masculinité
ordinaire et rasante épuisante dominante
non je voulais je voulais sortir
sortir
et volé mon volet gagné ma liberté parce
que sortir du labyrinthe
c'est gagner sa liberté
beaucoup
d'hommes et des femmes ont lutté pour
cela alors
il y avait abus bourguiba oui bien sûr
il est toujours là il est avec nous
les avocats hommes et femmes luttent
pour cela je voudrais penser à
dire un mot et me souvenir de notre
compatriote
ma consoeur gisèle halimi
qui a d'abord prêté serment en tunisie
faut pas l'oublier avant de prêter
serment en france
elle a été aux côtés de toutes les
causes
injustes elle a défendu la femme elle
était aux côtés de jamila vos papilles à
celle qui
a lutté pour libérer son pays l'algérie
colonisée
et puis aux côtés d'une autre femme anne
claire celle qui
était
dévoré par le liban libre un labyrinthe
de son violeur il faudrait que je vous
rappelle que
elle était mineure elle a été violée
et elle voulait se libérer de du
labyrinthe de son violeur donc est là
elle s'est fait avoir avorté et ça
donnait un procès qui fait date
aujourd'hui c'est le procès de bobigny
il ya un homme
avocat qui
lui aussi
était visionnaire
lui il à sauver un peuple entier
que dire il a sauvé un continent
il a sorti son continent de
ce labyrinthe de l'apartheid je veux
parler de nelson mandela madiba
j'ai eu l'immense honneur
d'être serrée par ses bras et de le
connaître et de l'entendre on ne parlait
de sa prison qui ne qui n'étaient pas
plus grande qu'un mètre et demi sur 3 m
mais il s'en est sorti il s'en est sorti
par le haut comme icare a essayé de le
faire sauf que
nelson mandela il a essayé de fédérer
tout le monde il a oublié la haine il ne
s'est pas engagée dans la vengeance il a
réconcilié tout son peuple toute
l'afrique tout le monde tout le monde
était derrière lui pour émanciper son
peuple c'est ça la liberté
et puis
aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup de
confrères hommes et femmes continuent à
lutter parce que c'est très très
important
gisèle halimi lorsque
elle a
décidé d'être aux côtés de ces femmes là
c'était pour
changer
d état d'esprit c'était pour faire
avancer la cause des femmes d'ailleurs
elle était sous l'emprise de cette
farouche liberté à charjah cheikh issa
le titre de le titre de son dernier
ouvrage traduit en langue arabe elle a
livré sa dernière plaidoirie pour la
cause des femmes est la cause des femmes
elle continue aujourd'hui à être défendu
par des bochra belhaj hamida qui elle a
essayé
tenter de changer la trajectoire de
l'histoire
sous
l'impulsion d'un autre grand visionnaire
à exception à l'arrière mot puisque on a
failli
et je ne désespère pas qu'un jour ça
arrive de changer la loi en matière
successorale
parce que c'est la femme c'est la femme
qui tient le foyer c'est la femme qui
est le squelette qui est le leur sort
cesser
la femme et et la moitié de l'homme et
si la moitié paralysé aucune nation ne
peut se redresser et se lever
c'est pour ça il faut il faut continuer
et pour moi en tout cas
là le désir de devenir avocate et ma
vocation est l'aîné de fait de ce combat
je me suis vu tout de suite avocate est
d'ailleurs ma première plaidoirie et
l'été par mois pour moi est contre moi
il fallait que je plaide il fallait que
je plaide pour trouver ma place dans
cette petite cellule d'abord cette
cellule familiale où il fallait quand
avec cinq garçons qu'on sache que
j'étais là
il a fallu que je fasse
des mouvements d'elle
d'une manière très répétées et c'était
c'était c'était exceptionnel c'était
extraordinaire parce que quand il ya la
réussite derrière lorsque vous tenez le
bambou c'est là vous vous dites que
c'est extraordinaire je suis je suis
arrivé
alors oui aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
différents différents procès
je suis face à ces
à ses victimes
ces victimes qui un moment donné même si
on garde notre carapace d'avocats on
s'identifie dans leur lutte dans leur
travail et de faire renverser la machine
judiciaire pour que la justice soit dite
et pour que la vérité éclate
je me suis vu noyer sur des rythmes
inconnus de la méditerranée comme ces
harraga les migrants qui au péril de
leur vie
ont pris la mer
sauf que comme icare beaucoup ont chuté
et se sont écrasés parce qu'on leur a
promis un avenir meilleur
je me suis vu aussi
face aux atrocités de dice cette
organisation terroriste dont le combat
mené par les chrétiens d'orient
je me devais d'être aux côtés des femmes
yazidi celles qui ont subi ces atrocités
qui ont été violées ainsi que leur fille
ces femmes là je me devais de leur
prêter ma voix parce qu'une société
sans voix c'est notre anéantissement
c'est l'obscurantisme
c'est ce que les accusés qui sont
aujourd'hui je vais le revoir demain
dans le box c'est ce qu'ils veulent
c'est à cela c'est très exactement leur
projet pour notre société c'est
l'obscurantisme
c'est le labyrinthe dans lequel comme
icare et son fils tourne tourne tourne
et cherche la sortie cherche le porte et
ils sont face à une impasse face à une
porte son secours s'en sont sortis je
pense je pense aussi à
lassana bâti 10 dans le procès de
charlie hebdo et de l'hyper cacher ce
jeune qui a
décidé de cacher au sous sol des
victimes et il a risqué
de sortir de par une part les dédales
par une sortie à l'arrière pour
demander de l'aide
et sauver des innocents la serna
baptiste eyraud
et hamadi coulibaly le terroriste qui en
a abattu trois tous les deux ils sont
nés d'humains pays ils sont tous les
deux maliens ils aiment parle le même
dialecte
tous les deux sont jeunes il ya une
année qui entre ces deux jeunes
sauf qu'il y en a un
qui a pu sortir du labyrinthe
lassana bathily l'autre le terroriste il
s'est enfoncé à jamais il ne se relèvera
jamais c'est ça le choix qu'il faut
faire pour sortir sortir par l'eau
le labyrinthe
que j'ai rencontré c'est aussi l'autre
c'est l'autre qui ne comprend pas
comment un avocat peut défendre
l'indéfendable
comment la justice peut traiter de
manière digne un accusés poursuivis pour
les pires mais les pires des infractions
comment expliquer à cette autre que
c'est ça la preuve que nous sommes du
bon côté nous sommes du côté de la
justice me semble du côté de l'état de
droit ne sommes du côté de la démocratie
et nous sommes loin très très très loin
du labyrinthe de l'obscurantisme
comment leur expliquer que oui que oui
il faut que nous avocats
puissions défendre l'indéfendable aussi
il faut le faire c'est notre mission
c'est notre vocation cette vocation est
l'aîné très très jeune chez moi
cette vocation a été encouragée par une
autre femme par ma mère déjà
elles
qui connaissent et
l'épreuve d'être femme
et la nécessité de se libérer des geôles
du patriarcat et de la tradition six
autres femmes qu'on est sorti toutes les
deux
nous avons nous sommes sortis par le
haut et je suis là devant vous
aujourd'hui et demain matin je serais à
la cour d'assises spécialement composées
alors je voudrais que vous le sachiez
toutes ces victimes
je les ai défendu
avec la même détermination
la même passion et la même douleur aussi
parce que pour paraphraser
simone de beauvoir on ne naît pas avocat
on le devient
la robe qu'un avocat porte c'est un
habit pour la vie c'est un deuxième
corps pour nous oui je défendre l
indéfendable
parce que je suis en dehors du
labyrinthe je ne suis pas tiré vers le
bas du labyrinthe dans l'obscurantisme
dans le noir absolu
et travaux cas c'est faire corps
faire corps avec la justice pour que
personne
personne personne ne puisse rester sans
défense
c'est très très important c'est votre
salut
alors aujourd'hui
je voudrais que vous sachiez une seule
chose
c'est que à tout moment
on peut reculer un peu chuté et on peut
s'écraser parce que les acquis ne sont
jamais acquis
a sonné et renforcer mais elle parce que
vous savez le contexte actuel nous
oblige à cela ça ne vous a pas échappé
la menace que la cour suprême des
etats-unis retirent le droit au vote
pour les femmes le droit de disposer de
notre corps et puis là me le martyre des
femmes afghanes
depuis le retour en politique des
talibans ces autres intégristes
islamistes qui pour eux la femme est une
burqa
alors j'aimerais aujourd'hui
voir pousser des ailes dans toute cette
salle et au delà de cette salle dans
toute la tunisie que j'aime tant je
voudrais pouvoir prêter mais elle a déjà
un ada une jeunesse qui désespère
parfois j'aimerais que mes mots
puissent faire pousser
des ailes
j'aimerais prêter des ailes à tous ceux
qui veulent se libérer et prendre leur
envol alors bon envol à tous
[Applaudissements]